[Musique]
pour moi c'est trop cher mais ça dépend
quoi si c'est les sacs
au football
[Musique]
ça nous a permis de jouer tout le temps
bon moi j'étais fou pour le
professionnel
je suis le terrain de sable et tout le
terrain synthétique tu peux jouer la
nuit déjà tu descends à 19h 20h tu veux
jouer 22h même tu peux jouer donc ça va
on avantage beaucoup plus grand que le
terrain sableux qu'on avait à l'avant
[Musique]
et c'était un terrain vague ici et
c'était mon un terrain de en sable où je
jouais régulièrement et donc passionné
de football l'idée m'est venue de faire
mon propre terrain à moi à la base c'est
un terrain tout simple et on y
réfléchissant jour et nuit
après c'est devenu un projet
[Musique]